I'm the first person to tell a
commissioner when I've lost confidence
in them and I share that with londoners
but also the first person seller
commissioner when he has my confidence
and share that with londoners and he has
my confidence
I'd lost confidence in the former
commissioner I I don't think why did you
lose confidence in her and not him uh
he's accepted uh the racism sexism and
the institutional part of it
he's not defensive uh he's not
resistance did you see my interview with
him no I'm sorry well trust me that he
is incredibly defensive and he doesn't
accept the full findings of the report
and he's also willing to engage with
communities look today's report
wasn't surprised to me it wasn't
surprised to me and it won't be
surprised to your viewers
who are people of color who are women or
who are from the lgbtq plus Community
because that's our experience of
policing for the last 20 30 years the
reason why this report is so important
it's not simply Dame news cases big into
londoners from those backgrounds but to
police officers and police staff who are
black Asian Marsh ethnic who are women
who are from the LG BG plus community
and what Dame Lou's Casey is demanding
is a complete overall I fully accept her
report I think the police service is
institutionally racist it is institutely
homophobic it is institution
misogynistic and that's already the
complete overhaul so the commissioner
should look again at accepting that then
well I've simply not seen the interview
he's quoted not just from speaking to us
this morning she doesn't accept that
it's institution sure I spoke to him
yesterday and he accepts fully the
issues around racism he also by the way
which is really important does not
accept and I never have this is just a
few bad apples this is just a few wrongs
these are systems and cultures that
allow out these behaviors to flourish
and Thrive to the point where if you're
a predator you're a pedophile you think
about joining the Police Service you get
a warrant card to do more bad things
Carrick and cousins are two such
examples and the unit that they were in
and Louise Casey says should be
disbanded he's not going to do that
either well he's not doing it today
because he's going to look at Parliament
and the Diplomatic Protection Team you
still need work to do I'm quite clear it
should be disbanded I'm quite clear some
of the practices that are taking place
in those units aren't fit for forget the
21st century any century and it's really
important that these cultures don't
allow officers to think they can get
away with this sort of bad behavior a
few half of londoners have faith in the
Police Service you're the boss of the
Police Service how much responsibility
do you have to take accept full
responsibility I've been looking into
the issue of that conference around the
country and not just the police service
so in London the really worrying thing
from the most recent crime survey
is only 51 of londoners have confidence
them at Police Service by the way it's
40 in Greater Manchester it's 49. we're
talking about what I'm making is this
the national problem and David you're
here to talk about London today damage
Casey talks about the devastating impact
of austerity her words not mine so what
we're trying to do
is bring about immediate change in
London that means changing how we
recruit how we vet how we supervise How
We Do misconduct some of these things we
need the government supports in vetting
and in misconduct already why have we
not done it before now well it's a
question for the homosexual when she's
here with you I'm quite clear in
relation to what I've done over the last
few years I was the guy that called for
an independent review Into The Police
Service I insisted that it should be
Dame Louise Casey I made sure he looked
at systems and cultures to shine light
in every part of the Met uh police
service and today's report has got to be
that wake-up call for anybody in denial
about the scale of the challenge the
mayor of London's for nearly seven years
now you have to accept some
responsibility that half of londoners
don't trust the service that you're
providing and that's why ultimately I
lost confidence in the former uh
commission look reforming the Met Police
Service is a critical part of my uh
mayorality Daily News case is not just
diagnosed as symptoms she's given the
prognosis and a route map how we get out
of here I'm determined to make sure we
accept all the recommendations to get
out of here including the fact that
potentially the Metropolitan Police
Service should be broken up yeah and
she's right to say that to you why
because look what she said is do these
things
uh and I don't think that Police Service
is too big to uh survive if you don't do
these things
you may look into you may need to look
into making them at Police Service
smaller I don't think we're there yet
because Dave news Casey has confidence
in me according to a report and the new
commissioner and the leadership team and
I'm determined to carry through those
changes but do you acknowledge that the
Metropolitan Police is potentially on
the verge of just being too big
yesterday as it is Damon's case also
found that Police Service defensive
resistance change are willing to engage
with communities by the way when I was
here more than a year ago I use words in
denial arrogant complacent uh to
describe them at Police Service and so
it's not just me saying it Dame Lewis
Casey's saying it as well so the police
can't ignore it in relation to the
changes uh required but it's right for
you to raise the question and the police
need to hear this if
there isn't the change there is a
possibility
uh if not this government a future
government will break up the police
service we need to realize that over
what period of time Dennis Casey uh has
said what do you think I think two years
I mean I've always said and Mark's
always to Mark's always said this Mark
began the job in October it just after
the Queen's funeral
uh you know he's been out of the police
over for four years his Deputy leonoris
was out of the police service but Police
Service for 10 years leaders in the Met
previously and they have to accept some
responsibility for the culture of the
Police Service in in London I think all
of us do David's cases says you know
listen next month is 30 years since
Stephen Lawrence has murdered a racist
murder it's now almost 25 years since
the MacPherson uh report you know Casey
talks about and not much has changed and
not much has changed and you've been the
mayor for nearly seven years yeah I'm
happy to talk about my record over the
last few years look so I'm the guy that
ordered a review Into The Gangs and
Matrix because of concerns in 2017 in
relation to disproportionality I'm the
person that asked the homologous
inspector should look into policing of
the Vigilant Clapham common I asked them
to look into concerns around the the
brutal murders by Stephen port in
relation to Easter I think they're still
rapist in the Police Service in London
uh I don't think anybody could answer
you that uh honestly yes how fearful are
you that that's the case uh
well one of the things that sir Mark's
done which will give you more confidence
is so Mark's going back over the last 10
years
any police officer or police staff
against human allegations been made uh
domestic abuse sexual offenses will be
looked at again
and sort of a better idea then because
you'll be aware uh you know cousins and
uh inverted commas slip through the net
Carrick in fact shouldn't have been in
the police in the first place and should
have been vetted at the regular veteran
interval and being kicked out and the
reports made about him and nothing was
taken so nobody can honestly answer you
that question yet will be in a better
position uh because sir Mark's ordered
an urgent review because it's called
operation Onyx will have a better idea
in the next few weeks and the police
services under special measures that's
not going to change anytime soon is it
no there are seven police forces around
the country in special uh measures one
of the things that the HMI have said
which I agree with
is what they don't want to Simply a tick
box exercise to say these things have
been satisfied they want to make sure
that any change is sustainable and
meaningful and it's really important
that change is sustainable and
meaningful because listen this isn't the
first report in relation to the Met
Police Service which will not look first
and 25 years ago what londoners want to
know is this will actually bring about
change someone just want to know Mr
Mayor they want to know that if they're
walking the streets of London tonight
they uh can have be completely safe in
the knowledge that they won't be
attacked by a rogue police officer I
agree they also want to make sure by the
way that if they are attacked by another
public the police will be there uh to
respond accordingly and so we've got to
make sure they are I was still advise
londoners as I do my daughters to report
things to the police
to trust the police we've got to make
sure though uh that that those londoners
who don't trust the police we earn back
their trust and you'd still have trust
in the Met absolutely but
um you know everyone in the police
service every single person the Police
Service needs to understand they have a
responsibility to bring about this
change it can't be just left to Sir Mark
and Damelin